foreign
part of me wishes we could have two
children and it's like no we I gotta
grieve that loss we're gonna be swimming
Upstream against a cultural current that
is so powerful here's what that cultural
current is feeling sad is something that
you need to fix
[Music]
the John deloney show I'm so glad that
you are with us
talking about mental health parenting
it's a call-in show with real people
going through real stuff and here's the
purpose of this show
take all my years of
training all my years of walking
alongside people when the wheels have
absolutely fallen off their lives
and the academic training
and just sit with you
sit with you when you're trying to
figure out what to do next whether
somebody you love has passed away
whether dealing with a mental health
challenge whether you're trying to
figure out how to grieve whatever is
going on in your life you're trying to
figure out where to send your kids to
school what's going on at work whatever
is going on in your marriage
I'll sit with you I mean I know the
answer I'm gonna sit with you and we're
gonna figure out what you can do next if
you want to be on this show give me a
buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 and listen it it makes
such a huge difference in this digital
world we live in if you will send
episodes to your friends or a particular
call to a friend say hey check this one
out you've been talking about your
husband's struggling pornography you
check this out your wife's struggling
with alcohol you can check this out send
these episodes to each other just get
them flying across the country because
it spins them up in the algorithm same
four or five star reviews same for just
hitting the Subscribe button it makes
such a huge difference just left the
meeting with Kelly looking at the show
numbers they're so staggering it's hard
to wrap my head around and so keep it
going we are getting people real help in
real time so thank you so so much way to
go way to go show team y'all are y'all
are just doing amazing work way to go
you and yeah yeah I'm the wink wink Link
in my own like no we kind of need you
here to do this yeah
but while I have you we're going to talk
about
hey questions for humans ten dollar sale
question for humans ten bucks 10 bucks
questions for humans we've sold jillions
and jillions and jillions of them if you
haven't picked them up they're on super
sale 10 bucks and I this this morning
this isn't a sales pitch I didn't
realize you're about to do this this
morning at my weekly uh Waffle House
breakfast with Hank I had the question
for humans parents for kids and here's
what's fascinating we've gone through
them before
um about six months ago and he's growing
and developing so fast that I asked the
same questions in a different we got
different answers we had different
conversations with it was a blast I have
one for us to do let's do it all right
what's the absolute worst physical pain
that you've ever felt oh
y'all go first I'll have to think about
this I've done a lot of stupid things
back there filling in for Jenna what do
you what do you think
the worst physical pain I've ever felt
um
I fell off a bus in Hong Kong
okay that's a great that's a great title
for a movie
fell off a bus in Hong Kong it's a long
story I'm not gonna tell right now but
fell off a bus in Hong Kong
twisted my ankle fell on it ripped my
ligament in half was so gross and I
threw up because it hurt so bad
and then did you go to a hospital in
Hong Kong I did and they didn't speak
English and it was a it was a whole
thing did they take care of you
Joe what's your worst pain
has to be when I broke my back
surgeries later how many five wow what'd
you do uh well the first surgeon wasn't
a good one and he screwed me up worse oh
man so how'd you break it in the first
place uh I used to work for the cable
industry okay and I was going to
reconnect a cable
in the middle of a field with you know
weeds up to my chest and didn't see a
gopher hole and I was carrying a 120
pound ladder
and everything just went down and
stopped if I would have fallen over
everything had been great but it just
you know
yeah it's kind of jumping into a pool
that you think six feet deep and it's
only three and it just yeah
oh man I hate that for you
Kelly
um I'm tempted to say so having a double
mastectomy not fun yes but there was
good drugs correct but the worst pain by
far is kidney stone
I've heard this to the death yeah I
I've never given birth so I will not say
it's worth worse than childbirth my
neighbor that came over to help me that
day had had three children naturally and
she said she would take childbirth any
day of the week I've heard that
repeatedly yeah but
um it was the first and only time I've
had pain bad enough that I threw up yeah
yeah and on the way on the car the way
the ER my husband I think thought I was
being a bit dramatic
and he he got I was throwing up and then
he got there and he's like but why is
she throwing up and the doctor looked at
me said the pain
it's like oh oh this is real so yeah
that was uh Andrew
uh I was a welder for five years
I got Burns all over John
it's bad time bad time bad time so were
you not a great welder that's why you're
here just kidding
I mean you know I'm here I'm here now
that's all that matters I'm trying to
think man I've had
so many injuries so many surgeries and
being in and out of whatever
what I'm gonna say is the truth and the
best like when you ask that question the
first thing that came to my mind
I was at a
Beach
with um I was like serving as like a
youth sponsor and there's all all these
high school kids and middle school kids
at a beach and I was helping somebody
who's older and I was like a sponsor
and they were all out there and I was
doing something in the van I was like
finishing something up in the van and I
got out and just like an idiot I went
sprinting into the water going
screaming as loud as I could
and there was a uh Railroad
uh like like the iron piece of a
railroad track someone had
but not not the wood it was the actual
track yeah the railroad tie it was in
the water and I kicked it like I was
just running going ah and I kicked it so
hard that my toe exploded but it was
from blunt force it was like from it was
there was nothing sharp on it it just
hit it so hard
and I remember being in the hospital
with my foot up and I had one toe poking
through the paper and somebody else
comes in and they're bleeding from their
head I mean it was so absurd I was in
there for with one toe
but dude I've been knocked unconscious
I've had stitches I've had my broke my
kneecap I've had all
I have never had pain like that it was
so unfathomable and I've had seven six
root canals I've had a bunch of those
and those aren't fun either but nothing
like that so my one toe Kelly that's
that's it America my one toe
you and your broken back Joe
my one two I'm yeah I need better
my life is embarrassing all right let's
go to Tim and Ventura what's up Tim
hey Dr John how are you I'm good man how
are you
good good I'm uh I'm really grateful to
be on I'm a long time listener and you
give great advice so that's why I'm
calling in well you're awesome hope I
can uh hope I can keep the keep the
trend going dude what's up
yeah I had a general question and we can
dig into specific details if it helps
out okay so my question is this what
does it mean when you say you need to
grieve and what I mean by that is
uh sometimes when someone like me is
going through you know life issues and
and it's and we're thinking oh I wish
life were like this I wish life were
like that if I wish you know I had this
kind of relationship with my family
and I listened to your show and you say
well you're living a fantasy you need to
learn how to grieve that loss and and
move on and I'm thinking that that
sounds great Dr John but what does that
mean you know what is what does grieving
look like exactly dude that's a great
question
um
do you have an example of something that
we could use as as kind of a model to
work through
yeah so I'm married to a wonderful woman
16 years we have a five-year-old son
and part of me wishes we could have two
children but even having one was tough
enough
and what was tough about it
so four years it took us four years to
even get pregnant and then we had a
miscarriage in the second trimester uh
it took another four years
to have this child Miracle child he's
his name's Kyle he's a ball of energy we
love them to death and we we just
couldn't go through you know trying
uh another you know a couple of years
for for a second and I guess one fantasy
I'm holding on to is I really wish we
had a second child
and it's like no we I gotta grieve that
loss but I just don't know I just don't
know what that means so let's replace
the word grief for a minute with the
word
experience
and when we use the word experience
instead of grief
we're gonna be swimming Upstream against
a cultural current that is so powerful
and here's what that cultural current is
feeling sad is something that you need
to fix
wishing and wanting something and
admitting it's not going to happen is
for losers and quitters for people who
don't want it bad enough
um
wishing something was different is is
ungrateful you should just be happy with
whatever you got
and so when I say that I want someone to
grieve the purpose of grief is
experience
for a moment sometimes and sometimes for
a long season
because I don't care what anybody says
if you lose a child there is no silver
lining
there's no
um God needed another Angel crap or
whatever stupid things get stitched on
pillows that people try to say in your
case
that now that you and this this happened
to me it took us four years to have Hank
Okay and then we had several
gnarly miscarriages this whole thing and
um then Josephine comes out of nowhere
okay so a similar track
um as you guys were on
I didn't understand that I had the
capacity for love and joy like I did
until I held my son
I didn't get it and especially um I
won't even be one of those dads like as
soon as I hugged him I knew I didn't I
mean it was just like a yelling lump of
uh screaming human it it evolved over
six months nine months a year right and
so
I've had the same thing too
like the thought of of just having had
Easter and we have three or four
Knuckleheads running around
like sounds amazing and it's not gonna
happen
it's not gonna happen so everything in
our culture says move on be grateful
don't be a whiner what grief is choosing
to sit for a minute or a an hour or a
day or a season
and just be heartbroken
let your body catch up to your spirit
how does that sound
it sounds it sounds good
but I I you know still more questions
come up three months bring them all on
bring everything because all the
questions you have are going to be
really helpful to people who are
listening yeah so so when I hear that I
I'm thinking you know how do I know if
I'm being successful at experiencing or
grieving how do I know it's not a
competition it's great grieving is not a
competition
people who compare grief my great he's a
extraordinary therapist his name is link
he's a he's a close friend of mine and
he was one of my crisis team partners
um
he lost a pregnancy
um that that him and his wife lost her
pregnancy later on than my wife and I
lost one of ours and I remember saying
to him
um
like I was so heartbroken and it was a
mess and in our home and I told him but
man I don't know anything about what
y'all went through and he looked at me
and said no no no no loss is lost you
don't compare grief
right so there's in grief as the great
David Kessler says uh it's
indistinguishable if it's it's I'm sorry
it's um unique
every everybody's grief is is like a
fingerprint it's different for everybody
and that's one of the things that breaks
up marriages is after six months
sometimes after the somebody loses a
parent after six months one of the
partners is like all right I'm ready
let's go do something fun
and then the other person looks at him
and just how could you possibly breathe
I'm not there yet right and that's hard
it's hard so to answer your question
there's not a right or wrong way there's
a couple of practices you can build in
there but
if you're looking for it to be the
answer to all things it won't be what it
does is um you ever been out in the
ocean swimming before
yep so you know when you're swimming out
in the ocean and also you can't touch
anymore and you're trying to like touch
touch touch and it you your heart just
starts beating a little bit faster
and then you start kicking your legs you
start kicking your arms a little bit and
then all of a sudden there's that moment
when your foot touches the ground
that's that's what grief gives you it
gives you Solid Ground to walk on again
you're still up to your neck and water
it's not like this person's coming back
it's not like suddenly your house is
going to be filled with people but you
can touch again and then you get to
figure out what we're going to do next
okay and then how do I know when I'm
done grieving like I often I hear you
say well you do you you need to write a
letter to your to the child that is was
never meant to be or you know picking up
bricks and you know putting masking tape
on it writing your you know writing
something on there and putting in your
backyard I'm like am I supposed to be
doing those things so in order to
complete the grieving process I think
it's incredibly important to have a
process and a a
for lack of better terms a ceremony
something to point back to
I have the names of the the babies that
we lost pregnancy all three of them
tattooed on my body and I did it on my
ribs where it would hurt the worst
and my wife and I had a small thing that
we did just very privately that I won't
talk about anymore
but all I have to say is I have a you
have a touchstone now that's why every
single culture has some sort of
um funeral some sort of honoring of the
Dead some form of honoring the passing
of
because you have to have a place to
Market
and that's why I'm really adamant that
that people take their kid parents take
their kids to funerals
because it just leaves an ellipse he
leaves a dot dot dot on their life on
relationships and kids it's just a it's
Mayhem so yeah when I tell somebody to
write a letter when I tell somebody to
carry a brick around when I tell
somebody to do a thing what I'm trying
to give them is a tangible moment in
history that they will always be able to
point back to
this is when I put a period at the end
of the sentence that was this person's
life this is what I put a period into
the sentence of this job of this breakup
of this marriage of this whatever of
this dream I had this is when I said
this isn't gonna happen
I'm gonna take another route but it's
good to always have a place to point
back to
so when here's how I I tell people quote
unquote you're done grieving I don't
know that you're ever gonna not wish
that something was different here's the
difference I know people are ready to
move on when their bodies no longer
react to the story
does that make sense that makes that
makes sense so let's and then like let
me just for people listening
um
there was a season when I couldn't talk
about
um especially the third after the third
one I couldn't talk about miscarriages I
couldn't talk about them
um I couldn't I don't want to talk about
them I don't want to discuss them I
didn't want to bring them up
uh cause my wife so much pain it caused
so much chaos in my house I felt so
inadequate because I didn't know what to
do I don't know what to say
um I was trying to solve all of my
wife's problems with charts and graphs
it was just a mess and so I didn't know
what to do
and so I just didn't want to talk about
it
once we sat down once I sat down went
through a formal grieving process I
entered into a season of sadness
I thought my life was gonna look
different and I thought these three were
gonna be a part of it and they're not
um now I'm at a place where I talk about
a lot from a teacher I can make meaning
of it and the meaning I'm going to make
of it is I'm going to teach people
here's how to how to do life when it
gets sideways on you so my body doesn't
take off on me anymore my heart rate
doesn't start beating I don't get that
warm weird heavy feeling in my stomach I
don't feel like I'm gonna just start
crying without it right so my body's not
taken off on me that's how that's
usually how people know but you're never
gonna not wish
is someone you love wasn't still with
you that's never going to go away
and what are some exercises that I can
practice where if I feel myself drifting
back into
that fantasy that that thing that I
thought I had finished grieving if I
feel like creeping up
what can I do to kind of interrupt that
that thought
so
um this is again from the great David
Kessler I think everybody who's
interested in learning more about grief
the greatest book I've ever read been a
part of seeing anything and I've been a
part of it I wasn't a part of it but
I've ever read I've I've I've probably
sold him a lot of books because I I'm
always giving it away and recommending
it to everybody it's called finding
meaning by David Kessler
um it's just a masterpiece when it comes
to grieving one of the key takeaways for
me in that book
um was this idea that
we are we we culturally we are beholden
to our thoughts and our feelings
we have to do whatever they say they get
to rule our world so if I feel a certain
way or if a thought just pops into my
head or in your case let's say you're
you're going to a ball field with your
with your you have a son or daughter
have a son okay so y'all are going to
play little league and you are walking
and you see a dad pile out of a junkie
Minivan and he's got four little kids
and a fifth one is a little bit older
and your heart just drops a little bit
that moment
I always thought that
I just I I didn't know there was another
alternative to that
and so one of the things Kessler talks a
lot about and I've taken what he taught
and I've taught it to a ton of people
who are like the last picture they have
of their kid is the funeral
the last picture they have of their
spouse is the funeral and like a
lightning bolt those pictures will zap
into their head or somebody who is
happily married and then their spouse
comes home and says I cheated on you
they have this image of their partner
with somebody else and it just shoots
into their mind like a lightning bolt
they can't get that picture I mean they
can't stop that picture from shooting in
there the moment you feel yourself
starting to feel that again that's the
moment you have a choice
and usually the best thing to do is to
have two things by your side number one
a picture to reinsert instead of the one
that just popped into your mind not the
picture of you sitting around an empty
Thanksgiving table but the picture of
you chasing your son around the yard
with him laughing and screaming in that
waddling wonky run that little babies do
the second thing is have a train of
thought a mantra a thing that you say
that is going to redirect your thoughts
in another Direction sometimes I'll be
walking through you've heard me say on
the show I'll be walking through the
house and I'll just yell out no I'm not
doing that I'm not having this
conversation with myself
I'm a blessed guy
I'm really blessed
and so I've got to step into those
thoughts and decide I want to disrupt
them it feels really good
to not good it doesn't feel good like
like a massage or like laughter and joy
but it's seductive it's a good on that
dark path and to say what if and maybe
if I had a different wife or if my wife
had been different if I had just done
these things differently if it's just
seductive to good on that route for a
hundred different reasons but it doesn't
serve anything because it's not reality
absolutely yeah that that's something I
am working on myself with exactly what
you said and I guess um I'll end with
this uh are the five stages of grief
real are those feelings or
you know
um are those things that you have to
experience to for grief to kind of run
its course or I'm not really too sure
about that yeah they're I like the I've
heard it said they're descriptive not
prescriptive
meaning it's a framework
but there's there's been research that
suggests they're no good
um for me they give me
um they're like floaties in the ocean
when I'm grieving something some in in
like we have words like for anger
well anger for me is a whole process
right it's a whole day
and then sometimes I'm grieving
something little like I wanted to be
there on time so I could meet my
daughter when she got out of school I'm
not gonna make it I'm not angry I'm kind
of sad
I'm kind of pissed off that I have a job
that had a deadline that I couldn't
right or denial like
some people go through wild denial right
they start going to do laundry of their
husband who passed away and they folding
clothes and put them in the drawers
right and then some people's denial is
like I just don't want to look at that
paper because I know it's in I know
that's the death certificate I don't
want to see it so I think they're good
touchstones but anybody who's like
looking to do a checklist for grief is
going to be disappointed because the
grief doesn't work like that
so maybe the best gift I could give you
is this
you sound like an analytical guy you
sound like a guy who wants to make sure
he's doing things the right way and
honoring his wife and honoring himself
and honoring his child and honoring
whatever situation you're grieving
um and the way you do that in your work
life in your regular life and I may be
out to lunch here but so tell me if I'm
wrong but the way you do that is you
make sure you account for all the
variables
you're probably great in Excel is that
right
yeah you hit around the head like Myers
Briggs I'm istj Enneagram six Super
security Focus there you go so here's
what here's what uh grief looks like for
you
open both hands
and hold them as high as you can
let go
what you're trying to do is control a
tidal wave
and you can't
you gotta let it wash over you and it
feels like grief will kill you and it
won't
it feels like it will drown you it feels
like it will take you out to sea and it
won't
the last thing I'll leave you with is
this dude and again thank you so much
for these probing questions these are
really important important questions and
they're ones I need to do a better job
of explaining on the show sometimes I
just blow by some of the stuff because
I've been through it so much
you cannot under any circumstances this
is physiological this is psychological
this is spiritual emotional whatever Al
Word you want to attach to this
you cannot
do grief alone
as David Kessler says grief Demands a
witness
so sitting down in front of somebody
else and reading the letter he wrote to
the kid that you're not going to ever
have
that's when the healing Journey Begins
telling somebody I really wanted this
marriage to work and you cheated on me
it's over
that's when Healing Begins
grief demands a witness you gotta have
other people in your life that you can
talk to
thank you so much for the call Tim
you've just helped a whole bunch of
people by being vulnerable and open
thank you so much we'll be right back
this show is sponsored by better help
folks take a minute to think about how
much time you spend on yourself it's
easy to get caught up in what people
need from you and want from you and
never think about what you need and then
you end up too stretched out burned out
all of the madness of our current world
resting on your shoulders
look sometimes I put my head down to
work and then realize I haven't had a
meaningful conversation with my wife and
kids all day I get focused on what I'm
doing and I'm running and running and
running
and I don't know how to come back
and therapy is a great way to learn new
skills that make you the best version of
yourself they help you set boundaries
and still have energy left to help
others without leaving yourself behind
so if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
totally online to fit into your schedule
you just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge so find
more balance find Wellness with better
help visit betterhelp.com deloney today
to get 10 off your first month that's a
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we are back
um I missed this in the last call so I
just want to the last call we talked
about grief if you're watching this on
YouTube
um go check out the other call with Tim
from Ventura California on Grief
I did send him a copy of own your past
change your future
um
it's a number one best-selling book that
I wrote uh it's got a step-by-step
process for how to grieve and grief is
simply this the way I Define it is it's
the gap between what I wanted what I
hoped would happen
what I wanted to happen in reality what
actually happened and what do you do in
that space between I wanted you to live
forever I wanted this marriage to be
forever I wanted you to never be a
person that lacked Integrity I wanted
you to always tell the truth never cheat
on me whatever
um I didn't want another country to
invade my like I just wanted the
stability and peace for my little family
it's that Gap and so there's a
step-by-step process and on your past
change your future we'll link to it in
the show notes along with David
Kessler's amazing book Finding meaning
and um but you can pick those books up
today all right let's go to Rose in
Springfield what's up Bros
hello hello
how are you incredible how are you
I'm good good what's up what are you
doing
uh well uh just waiting around for you
to pick up my phone call that's what all
right well I got you what's happening
let's do this
um so I guess I'm looking for guidance
on how to
navigate a
uh I've I've come to realize over the
course of our relationship that I think
he's on the Spectrum
and I I don't know how to tell them
because I know if I tell them
um it's going to be an insult to him
he's he was he's been insulted his whole
life he had like a really hard childhood
every mean thing any adult figure could
have ever said to him they said it
um you know verbally physically abused
like
um
uh and so to you know so I understand to
like bring that up shouldn't be an
insult to someone but it might be to him
just considering he's been degraded so
much for through his whole life and I'm
just sensitive to that and and then the
other thing is is that now that I've
become aware or I've come to believe
that he's on the Spectrum
so many of our arguments kind of make
more sense in hindsight uh
and I'm trying to learn how to like
support him or like air quotes argue or
communicate properly and I don't know
where to start and I don't know where to
get him resources and I don't know where
to get resources for myself and so then
that's why I'm calling you I appreciate
that
um
okay
so two things well let me ask your
permission can I be super honest and
straight and direct with you is that
cool yes okay awesome
um
I guess one one day Rose someone's gonna
tell me
um no I prefer you just tell me exactly
what I would like to hear and haven't
nobody's done that yet so okay
first thing here
I would with all of my heart all of my
guts all my strength in mind would tell
you don't be in the business of pseudo
diagnosing people that you love and care
about
right I would whatever
I imagine you are reaching for somebody
you love how can I love you better so
it's not like I'm not trying to beat you
up over it what I'm telling you is
um as the great brene Brown says what we
go looking for in the world we are sure
to find
and when we put Diagnostics glasses on
and we begin looking through the world
we will see them everywhere I could give
you a
um series of uh
behaviors
that would suggest he has depressive
disorder and if you put those glasses on
you would see it everywhere and I could
give you another series of behaviors and
responses and reactivities uh with
anxiety disorder and you would see it
everywhere so I always want to be
careful about putting those glasses on
okay
um
the second thing I want you to really be
careful of as you're heading into this
marriage and we'll get to the autism
conversation here but it all works it's
all synergistic here
you cannot build a marriage on trying to
hedge truth in conversations
the goal can't be how do I tell how do I
do a thing how do I respond a thing do I
a thing I think my husband has but I
don't want to tell him he's got it I
just want to start doing these things
because that's always going to fall down
at some point
so the goal the goal is how do we come
to an understanding together that the
way we are communicating with one
another the way we are experiencing each
other is not working and one of the
things might be because my husband has
perception challenges or feels
exceptionally it feels powerfully about
things right
um so uh or is it lacks a little bit of
empathy or is also over empathetic it
shuts his body down right so
you see the difference there
uh like you said pseudo diagnose and and
that's where I'm just kind of lost and I
don't know what to do so if I'm in your
seat if I'm in your exact seat the
conversation I would have
verbatim would be
I love you so much
and I want some tools so that I can do a
better job of communicating with you
I'm not doing a good job of telling you
my needs in a way that you can hear them
and understand them
and I'm not doing a good job of hearing
and responding to your needs
would you be willing to go see a
pre-marital counselor with me and in
this situation not some
buddy who's like done a bunch of
weddings and they make you go through
three things in a workbook but I'm
talking about a true marriage counselor
who also by the way has the licensure
the ability and the experience to do
diagnostics
and once you lay out a series of here's
how were some of our communication
challenges are happening
every Bell in that therapist office
should go off if it's a true autistic
diagnostic
does that make sense yeah no
no and I know he'll he'll like that idea
and he probably feels it deeply right
oh yeah yeah because we've we've talked
about
like our miscommunications like
um
we know there's a disconnect
yeah he knows that there's a disconnect
some you know at times we are getting
better at communicating and realizing
you know the differences
um
but you know he is a Christian and I do
believe that he would love to do
premarital counseling so so oh and
I've got tons of friends who are pastors
I want to steer you away from just doing
traditional pastoral
um oh no yeah I want
I want to see someone who can diagnose
there you go that's right and so and and
here's where so on one hand I was just
telling you I don't like Diagnostics
like just as a blanket but there's some
great utility they serve a good purpose
and here's a great a great place
right now I can imagine
when the lights are low
your fiance thinks he's doing something
wrong he's screwing something up
he thinks that all the time all the time
he thinks he's one giant big screw up
like all the time yes and he's got so
much he's got trauma in his background
he's got abuse and all the stuff going
on in his past
and a diagnosis would be able to say hey
your brain and body simply interacts
with the world in a different way
and so since it does great
you are not a Kim Olajuwon you are not
seven feet tall with a great fade away
you are Steph Curry you're I don't know
five eight you're gonna have to to be
successful in basketball you just have
to do different things you're gonna have
to learn to shoot the ball from really
far away cool
you're not taking you off the field
we're just going to tell you hey you're
not ever going to be a good post player
because you're you're 5 10 or whatever
tall Steph Curry is it's a very similar
situation here I remember some peace
when I was told
hey if we were going to do diagnostics
here here's what you would have
and I'd be like ah okay
it gives me a place to start from
it's not an ex it's not an excuse it's
just a context right so I think it could
be helpful or for you it could be
helpful to find out no he's not autistic
he's not
um
but do you love him yes cool then we're
going to figure out how to communicate
together and there is
I I have no qualms at all about marrying
somebody on the Spectrum none zero
yeah I mean I I initially couldn't tell
um I did have a friend who told me like
right off the bat but I didn't believe
her I was like no no he doesn't but
um I guess she had more experience in
that world than I do so she saw it
faster and it took me longer to like
clue in
um I used to work with actually severely
autistic children in preschool
um but he's very high functioning um he
actually has a doctorate in chemistry
um so it just took me
longer to figure it out in him if he is
truly autistic it may have been a
superpower in his chosen profession
and similarly
boxers with who are just innate they're
born with great hand speed it is
incredible for their job but they have
to learn a different way to interact at
home
and that's what we're talking about here
even if some of it's going through the
motions
right maybe he will never be able to
walk home and feel how you are how your
day went
but he can learn the six questions that
he's going to ask when he walks in the
front door all six of them pertaining to
you and how are you
and you're going to learn maybe it's not
that he's not empathetic maybe your
feelings are so intense they burn his
skit like it just burns a hole through
him like fire and that's why he
just stare straight ahead and so you
might have to learn how to regulate see
you see what I'm saying it's just going
to be a dance that y'all are going to
have to have to learn but dancing is so
fun if you have the right Spirit about
it right
right yeah cool
so I would I would I would hold off on
saying the man that I love is a is this
fill in the blank diagnosis I would be
all about hey let's learn some new
skills let's go see a professional let's
go sit down and figure this stuff out
together the focus y'all are gonna have
is communication telling the truth
learning how to see and
um depending on where he falls on the
Spectrum with intuition
um and then learning about like some
things aren't about routines and some
things aren't uh you can't logic your
way through grief you can't logic your
way through pain and hurt and all that
kind of stuff
um sometimes you have to sit in and you
have to feel and so it's just going to
be people learning new skills people
people learning new skills I've got no
doubt y'all can make this happen let the
professional do the diagnosing let the
professional put that on the table you
just show up and say I want to be the
best supporter and best friend and best
wife I can be
and hope your husband shows up too thank
you so much for the call we'll be ready
yes before we go to break I'd like to
point out Steph Curry is 6'2 he's held
tall six two it's not like he's you know
he thought he was like five six six he's
six two so that's how tall I am good
grief well there I go on that one yeah
just when you see him again with his
teammates well when he said indexes
someone that's seven foot tall
but he's six two he's not short by any
stress Well Steph Curry is a huge fan of
the show stuff I'm sorry I'm sorry
that uh I made you feel small
you're six two we're the same height I
challenge you to a basketball game
anytime you're up for it bring it we'll
be right back
all right uno mas let's go out to Alex
in Orlando Florida what's up Alex
hey Dr John how are you sir I'm good man
how about you
doing wonderful beautiful day here in
sunshine Florida I can't complain that's
awesome it's a stunning day here in
Nashville it's beautiful in Tennessee
what's up wonderful hey how can I help
guide my parents more specifically my
dad
two smoke-free way of living
it's tough man
that's real how old is he it is my my
dad's a 66 and uh my mom's 71 and my dad
just had a heart attack a few weeks ago
yeah the reason why I reach out to you
is because
um you know he he spent two days in the
hospital and as soon as he came out of
the hospital you know I called to follow
up with my mom that night and I talked
to her and and uh you know I said you
know is he is he still smoking and she
first says to me no he's not and I said
mom come on what's going on she said
well he he did just just one time just
one cigarette just three times you know
just really trying to justify it
and my grandparents died early and you
know I just we have a son of of our own
and I want my dad to be around and I
want my parents to be Rhonda
to even get older have you looked him in
the eye and told him those exact words
I have not I'm terrified to do it that's
it
I'm gonna tell you right now
um you've probably heard me say this on
this show not by your hand but in your
lap
here's what I mean by that there's lots
of problems historically that have
happened that I played no part in
but they're still here in my culture and
I gotta deal with it right or sometimes
your house may flood because your
neighbor left the water on at some point
doesn't matter who left the water on
it's flooded my house I gotta deal with
it okay
you didn't cause this you didn't this
has nothing to do with anything you've
done
but you found yourself in a position
where you can either be terrified having
this conversation I promise you
you won't sleep for the rest of your
life
if or when your dad does pass away and
you don't have this conversation
right
so you didn't cause it but it's a
conversation you have to have if nothing
else just so you can have some peace
when when he actually
heads out
right
so uh do you all live in the same
neighborhood y'all live far away
far away he lives in uh in Texas okay
um
because they're coming to visit us very
soon he actually here's another kicker
for you Dr John is he actually wants to
help us build a fence in our house in
the month of June in Florida
have you ever heard of
the the delusional male
my dad is one of the hardest working
guys you'll ever meet in your life he
actually had a heart attack after
helping people in his neighborhood in
his area by chopping wood for eight
hours to ten hours on end yes I got a
buddy one of my best friends in the
world is Dad's in his 90s and uh
he just got put on hospice his terminal
cancer said he doesn't want to go
through all the rigamaru and the hospice
nurse showed up for the first time and
she couldn't find him and he was
planting rose bushes in the backyard in
Texas
well and here's the deal at some point
I'm not going to take that from you
like what's the alternative you just sit
on the couch you'll die fast right it's
I'm not going to take that from somebody
who's wired that way your dad's 66 not
93.
as 30 years
true that's your son being two two uh
two kids into his life
see what I'm saying
yeah
um
man I can preach really big right now
I would have a hard time not getting on
an airplane and flying to Texas to look
my dad in the eye in his environment
if he's going to be there in a month
then that's up to you
you always run the risk of these kind of
conversations of him packing up and
going home and it's different when you
can take off and leave
right
um but it may be a conversation that you
want to have before he comes and stays
with you it's a conversation that has to
be done face to face and I'd recommend
writing a letter and reading it to him
because it's just gonna be tough to get
through if you just want to wait that's
a great idea
and it would start with it's just hard
enough to talk to you about it no yeah
it's I mean
um
if you can man if you have a good dad
like you
my dad lost his dad at 93 or 94. and he
told me my dad was in his late late 60s
early 70s and he said it was unmooring
that was the exact same age as me when
when his dad passed exact same age I am
now I think that's how you start the
letter
when's the last time you looked your dad
in the eye and told him these words I
love you
um the last time he visited me okay so
y'all say that regularly yes yes sir
okay we grew up uh I grew up very close
to both my parents
um more specifically my dad and they
were always in my life every sport every
all through college all through
everything so okay great parents
um I think that's where you start man
so it sounds like what's hard about this
is less about your dad's gonna get mad
and kick you out and more hard like this
means you've gotta you've got
you're coming to terms with the fact
that your dad's not gonna live forever
correct
yeah that's a different conversation
that's one about Grace and love and
I want you to be here for every second
not about power and move you see what
I'm saying this is a different
conversation correct exactly correct so
I'll tell you this will be one of the
hardest things you ever do but it will
be one of the most beautiful things that
um
you will experience in your life even if
it goes awful it will be beautiful
because you got to look the most
important man in the entire world to you
in the eye and say I love you and I love
you this much
please stop please be around here a
little bit longer
and if you want to play dirty you want
to play dirty which hey when it comes to
saving lives I'm all about it you can
slide a photograph that you've had
printed off like at Walgreens of you and
your son
and you can say if not for you for us
in in counseling when we have somebody
who yells at their kid
one of the things we will do sometimes
is ask them to get a picture
of their child one of their children
and every time they're about to scream
and yell
pull that picture up and look at it and
say
um
I care so little about you I'm about to
let your mama have it
or we'll ask them to carry a picture of
their stepmom or their stepfather who is
abusive and they'll pull that picture
out and say hey I care more about
modeling what you did than my little
boy's feelings I'm about to do what you
taught me and literally the behavior
goes away
and so that's cheating it's not cool
it's plain dirty but in this situation I
I mean I'm all for it I would pull out
every stop I have but to stop being
you're not trying to convince some
bullheaded [__] that won't listen to
you and has been blowing you off your
whole life
you're trying to tell a man
who's a great guy
I love you this much
correct yeah
dude he's lucky to have you man
I'm not gonna have both of them you're a
hell of a son man
thank you how old's your little one
he's uh just turned 13. hmm
if you want to play super super dirty
you can have him write a note too
[Laughter]
much involved in all that okay gonna say
something bananas
what's up he's involved
it's true it's true
and even if nothing else the opportunity
for him to write a letter to a Granddad
just to say hey I got scared and I love
you
then you have to mention the smoking but
just giving him an opportunity
would be a pretty neat moment
be a pretty cool
fact I appreciate that a lot because of
this conversation my son's 13 and my dad
came and visited us this past weekend
and just took off I'm gonna have my son
write my dad a letter uh this week too
in honor of Alex thank you for inspiring
me to do this because it'll be an
important moment for my son too
thank you Dr John you're awesome my
brother hey uh let me know how that
conversation goes Alex
um
I'd love to share how that went and if
you want to be super dope super Brave
I'd love for you to come back on the
show and read that letter to our
audience there's probably zero to uh
less than zero chance that you that your
dad listens to us so
um if you do want to give an example to
our listeners of
um your fellow deloniites what a letter
like this might look like that would be
incredible I would really uh it'd be an
honor but thank you for your bravery go
call your old man and tell them that you
love him and you want to beat him to be
around for 20 or 30 years we'll be right
back
[Music]
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right we are back some of you write
me direct messages sometimes you shoot
me emails or write me letters which I
just love I love getting mail
and you tell me
things like I bet Kelly's holding the
whole show together or you need to just
be nice to Kelly because she's the best
in the world
she doesn't have a tiny cold dark heart
you do deloney she's wonderful
here's the song she picked for today
Eric Church's
Smoke a Little Smoke
[Laughter]
and I'm the bad guy way to go America
way to go
turn the quiet up turn the noise down
let this old world just spin around
I want to feel it swing I want to feel
its way want to put some feel-good in my
soul drink a little drink
and just say no when it comes to smoking
want a little more right a little less
left a little more right now a little
less what's next act like tomorrow's 10
years away and just kick back and let
the feeling flow drink a little drink
and don't smoke
I set my sails for a new Direction but
the wind got in my way I changed my
course but my definition of change just
ain't the same
I could get up and go get her back oh
you couldn't Eric or maybe I'll just let
her go and drink a little drink but I
won't smoke cause it's not good for you
Kelly unbelievable hey love you guys
stay in school see ya